All right, Ladies and gentlemen, welcome to
the webinar today on the bulk conversion of
gi's to Accession.Version.
I am Eric Sayers and will be speaking to for
a few minutes about this topic.
If there are questions we do not get to today,
we will be posting answers to the questions
with the other webinar materials.
You can find that at the webinar's page listed.
There is also a go USA.gov URL to the materials
and those will be up later today.
Let's get started.
What we'll talk about today this is essentially
the third webinar in a series of webinars
about changes to sequence identifiers at NCBI.
I am just switching for a moment to a command
line.
I will tell you what I am doing in a moment.
I will start a process that I will explain
later.
Off it rurns.
We will come back to that in a moment.
What I would like to do is talk to you about
a couple of different things that we have
been attempting to do with GI numbers and
accessions.
One of the things we talked about in the last
few webinars on July 20 and September 7 is
the fact we have been changing some of the
ways we are dealing with sequence identifiers.
The main thing that is happening is that sequences
that have GI numbers will continue to have
GI numbers going forward.
More and more new sequences will not be assigned
GI numbers.
We are going to be switching to Accession.Version
as the primary identifier for sequence records.
That is something everyone needs to be more
aware of.
You can go back and look at those two webinars
we had before to understand more about that.
I want to talk a little as introduction to
the webinar about something we talked about
on September 7 which is how you can use efetch
to handle a certain number of GI numbers and
convert them to Accession.Version.
One of the things we understand is as this
process unfolds you may need to convert GI
numbers in existing systems to Accession.Version.
The real motivation behind what we are doing
today is that you can do many more if you
want.
Again to summarize the things that are changing.
We are phasing out the usage of the sequence
identifiers called GI numbers, existing GI
numbers will remain indefinitely.
If a sequence has a GI number now it will
continue to have a GI number.
You can continue to use that for retrieval.
The real issue are sequences that will not
have GI numbers assigned to them.
Those sequences in particular are things like
WGS and TSA which many do not have GI numbers
now in any case.
More and more of those will continue not to
have them.
Though sequences are a problem in terms of
trying to get GI numbers currently . That
problem will continue to grow as we are unable
to assign GI numbers.
Currently blast FASTA databases do not contain
GI numbers anymore and you will not see them
on the default web displays of sequence records.
For example the flat file records and FASTA
formats do not have them by default.
I should emphasize that GI numbers are still
present in records that have them; they are
just not displaying on the web displays and
things like the blast definition line.
After March 15, of next year, none of the
formats, flat file FASTA record formats, will
contain GI numbers including the GenBank and
RefSeq releases.
We realize if you already have a system that
has G.I.
numbers in it you will need to convert them
to Accession.Version.
On September 7 and the last webinar we talked
about a way in which you can use the efetch
E-utility to do this for a smaller number
of GI.
So if you have on the order of several hundred
or maybe a small number of thousands you can
do it.
I won't talk about this in detail you can
go back to the webinar but the basic idea
is you can use an API call such as shown here
to get back a list of Accession.Version that
conform or correspond to the inputs of GI
numbers.
Including bad GI numbers.
So 100 for example is no longer a valid GI
number.
The record was removed.
If you do that you will get a blank in your
output.
That works fine if you have a small number.
The real question we had to address is what
if you had a large number.
You can do about maybe 250 or so; if you use
the HTTP POST, maybe around several thousand.
Because of our policy of use of APIs, no more
than about three calls per second.
If you have hundreds of thousands or perhaps
millions of GI you need to convert this is
not the most practical way to do it.
What other thing could we offer to allow bulk
conversion.
Enter this new resource that we have now released
on our FTP site.
The resource is actualy two things.
It is a Python script called gi2accession.py.
And an accompanying database that contains
all the information.
The database is actually in binary so you
won't be able to look at it directly.
You need the Python script to de-encrypt the
database for you.
The script is designed to run locally.
The idea is you would download this onto your
own machine.
That is great because you don't depend on
it on a network connection or API anything,
you just have to get on your own machine.
You need to be aware the database file is
large.
It will be about 40 gigabytes when you uncompress
it.
Need to have some space on the disk to contain
it but you can get it and use it locally.
The database file contains all GI numbers
that exist.
Including nucleotide and protein, GenBank,
RefSeq, you name it they are all there including
old GIs.
So GI from previous versions of records.
Everything's there in one place.
We are updating the database every day.
That's useful to know.
The database changes every day.
If you get it on one particular day you will
get the snapshot of the database at that time.
If you need to do this conversion process
again, you may want to come back and get the
most recent copy of the database to make sure
you have full coverage.
One thing we anticipate about this is it probably
for many folks, is a one time operation and
that you already have a database of GIs.
One time you can do a conversion and map the
two and that is all you will need to do.
Then you can continue to update your local
databases and other services.
Is not something we envision as being an on-demand
service to be used frequently.
If that's not the case for you please let
us know.
That's why we designed this is one bulk download
that you can do once and get it over with.
How you get this.
It lives in the FTP site, genbank/livelists/giacc_mapping.
You go there and you find a number of different
files.
One of the files will be gi2accession.py and
the other file will be this gi2acc_lmdb.db.gz.
That is the thing you need to download.
That is about nine gigabytes compressed.
You also find a number of other files which
are older snapshots of that single database
file.
If you point to this particular file name
you will always get the most recent version
of the file.
That is the one to remember if you want to
go back and get an older one you can do that.
[gi2acc_lmdb.db.gz]
Also a useful thing to know is we have checksum
files for that database file also in the FTP
site.
You can see them there.
You can use either one of those to perform
a checksem after you download it.
It's a useful thing to do to make sure download
is complete.
How do you install?
First obviously unpack the archive.
Then it will blow up about four fold.
To about 40 gigs of space that you will need.
You need a Python environment of some kind.
We tend to use virtual environments here.
There's a variety of ways you can do it.
You need a 2.7 or later Python environment.
You need the lmdb package.
We put here a simple pip command that you
can use to install it.
Once you get the package that's all you need
and you should be good to go.
The script runs in two different ways.
In one way it's interactive.
The idea here is that you can just put in
a number and a number and you will get back
the G.I.
That is what I show here in the top.
You run the script it prompts you for the
GI number you give it the GI number.
Then it gives you a line with numbers in it.
There is actually a formatting problem here.
The first number is the GI, the second up
to the point one is the Accession.Version,
and this 416 which got dumped up.
I apologize this is the sequence length.
Another way you can do it is which is probably
the more useful way, this is a useful check
to see if the script runs and is it functioning.
Is to give it a file of a bunch of gi's.
What you can do there's a number of ways you
can do it.
Take a file, put one GI per line and pipe
that into the script.
It will take that and output one line that
looks like this.
It will give you the GI, the Accession.Version
and the sequence length back.
Okay a live demo.
Hopefully we will have fun with this and nothing
terrible will happen.
Let me show you - - let me show you what I
have.
I am in a linux environment.
I have a few files here.
I have my script.
Here is the gi2accession.py script.
The rest of this is some Python files and
if I was simply to run the script like this
it gives me a prompt.
And so if I was to enter the number 42 it
gives me that back.
I can keep going.
If I know another GI number, it will give
me something back.
If I enter something that is not a GI number
it tells me it is not found.
This allows you to say does it work or not
work.
And control C control D any of those characters
will take you out.
The more interesting thing is if you have
a large number.
Let's imagine I have a file.
What I've done is prepared a simple file.
It only has six GI numbers in it.
That's the kind of file you would need as
input.
Then I can have the script and I can input
that file directly into the script and I get
the output.
The output, 1 is not a valid G.I. 10 the accession.version,
100 is not a valid G.I.
here's another one and another one.
Notice that it's agnostic about whether it's
nucleotide or protein.
Those of you who have been around NCBI long
enough and use the resources may realize that
CAA, three letter prefix accession is a protein,
and NP underscoreis a protein.
These guys down here are nucleotides.
Doesn't tell you that.
The point is it's a simple mapper between
a G.I.
number and Accession.Version.
How much can you do and how long does it take?
Not to bore you with having to wait around
I went ahead and created a file of GI that
include all the primate refseq GI's in nucleotide.
It turns out there's a bunch of GI.
If you look at how many there are, there's
about 2.8 million of those.
That's a reasonable number in terms of what
you may want to convert.
How long does it take the script to convert
that many?
In my hands it took me 10 minutes.
It's a quick process.
You can have hundreds of thousands and millions
of these things you will get a quick conversion.
I get a whole big file with lots of things
in it.
One of the things that I would point out since
I did this and I was like this is interesting
it's a good thing to know there's a lot of
not found things here.
What I did was I downloaded the database on
one day and did the test the next day.
Most of these that you see are brand-new.
They are not found.
When you see not found be aware it could be
that it's an old GI and its not existing anymore.
Or could be that it's brand-new.
Remember the database is updated with thousands
of GI every day.
You want to run at the same be to make sure
you get the most accurate information.
I would probably guess for most people it's
not a big issue because you are dealing with
the GIs you already have.
In any case be aware that's the dynamic.
Let me go back to the PowerPoint after we
survived that.
And finish up.
Some other things that will be happening in
the near future.
In one of our previous webinars I believe
it was the September webinar we talked about
a new ID type parameter for the E-utilities
that is almost ready and should be going out
in January.
That will allow E utilities to accept accession.version
as their ID and allow them to output those.
If you want more details refer back to the
September 7 webinar where we discussed that
in some detail.
We will have much more publicity as it goes
forward.
Also keep in mind the March date when the
GI will no longer be available in any of the
flat file or FASTA presentations; that includes
all the things on the FTP sites.
I will pause here and thank everyone for your
attention and if there are questions please
let us know.
Okay Eric we have several questions.
One question is what about the other databases
linked in NCBI, will they continue to have
GIs?
I'm not sure I understand the question completely.
We have no control about what happens to the
outside databases.
If you want to clarify please type it into
the questions pod.
The second question is which non-database
method is appropriate for 50-500 G.I.
numbers.
If you have a small number 50-500, either
way works.
You can certainly use one efetch URL to do
that number.
That should be fine.
That means you don't have to download the
database.
And use disk space.
I would probably say use efetch if you have
a small number.
The script and the database is designed I
would say if you have more than 10,000.
The last question has to do with blast.
About the blast being updated to handle GIs.
That's already the case with the current version
of blast which is 2.5.0+ works with accessions.
Keep in mind the G.I.
numbers are present in the preformatted blast
databases.
You can continue to use those as you have.
And the other question is I'm not sure why
GI is changed to accession maybe the question
is why we made the change.
The basic question is like why is this happening?
A couple things we can say is in general over
the course of time we have had two different
ways of identifying sequences.
One being the G.I.
numbers and one being accession.versions.
In fact both of these identifiers are redundant
in that they each uniquely map to a particular
sequence record.
Most publications in journals require accession
numbers for publication of sequences that
is a more typical way referring to sequence
data.
Another advantage of the Accession.Version
over the GI is as mentioned earlier many of
the sequence databases do not have G.I.
numbers.
Important resources such as the WGS data set
and TSA simply do not have G.I.
numbers at all.
The only way we can refer to those sequences
is by Accession.Version.
We are moving towards a point where we can
universally access all the sequence data at
NCBI in a consistent manner and that would
be Accession.Version.
A follow-up question I think about blast for
making the G.I.
lists and things like that to limit database
access in blast so you can pick which sequence
you use.
There is a seqid list option that can use
accession numbers.
We are working on making that option faster.
One problem is the index is slower to run.
We are working on making that faster.
I am not sure if it will be out in the next
release, you can currently do them with accessions
but they will not be as fast as the GI number.
A couple more questions.
It would be helpful to know what the most
popular letter prefixes on the ID that's refer
to.
Some of that stuff is on our website, the
refeq accessions in particular.
For the INSDC, the submitted accession numbers
that's more complex and sometimes they are
arbitrary.
The last question that we will take is if
I submit a new sequence it will have a new
accession or version update of an older sequence?
I think I understand that.
The answer to that is, if you submit a new
sequence you will get a brand-new accession
number.
It will be version 1.
We are continuing to assign accession numbers
because that space is huge we can continue
to do it forever.
I think that's all we have time for today.
If you have another question that is in the
chat pod we didn't get to, we will answer
it in a document.
I will turn it back to Eric now.
Thank you, Peter.
Thank you for your attention.
Hopefully this will be a useful utility for
you.
Give it a try and see what happens.
Let us know.
If you have any questions about that or problems
with that you can write to info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
I put some additional other points of information
up here.
You can follow our blog which is NCBI Insights
in the NCBI news and other social media, our
Facebook and twitter channels for upcoming
announcements about GI and accession number
issues.
When they will be released and what other
changes will happen.
We will do additional webinars on the topic.
If you are particularly interested in the
API, utilities-announce is an email listserv
for where we announce such changes for the
community.
You may want to sign up for that.
There's a link on the slide.
Certainly you can write to info if you have
additional questions.
If there are no other questions, I bid you
all happy holidays and thank you for your
attention and hope to see you soon.
Thank you.